[Musica]
i miei progetti sono mossi
dall'altruismo e dall'inclusione che
sono valori a me cari; ciò è dovuto a
esperienze caratterizzate
dall'esclusione e dall'indifferenza ho
subito vari episodi di razzismo che mi
hanno portato non soltanto sentirmi
discriminata ma in difesa sola e
soprattutto diversa ciò che provocava
grande dolore Era il silenzio delle
persone che mi circondavano degli amici
ed ai compagni complici in questa
situazione infatti queste situazioni è
agghiaccianti avvenivano e tuttora
avvengono a scuola che viene chiamato
luogo inviolabile luogo che dovrebbe
combattere questo tipo di comportamento
ma purtroppo non accade non accade tra i
compagni e non accade nemmeno tra i
docenti e a volte diffuso dai professori
stessi
infatti in classe si discuteva di
tematiche di attualità sui migranti in
fuga sugli sbarchi e in quei momenti una
soffocante attenzione veniva rivolta
verso di me
e qui usciva la solita domanda Ma i tuoi
sono venuti col barcone o in aereo e io
li rimanevo senza parole senza
meccanismi di difesa senza risposte
soltanto il grande silenzio
e purtroppo queste situazioni non erano
semplicemente limitate alla scuola ma
avvenivano anche nei luoghi pubblici per
esempio Quando compravo qualcosa le mie
banconote venivano stranamente
controllate Ovviamente questi controlli
casuali non avvenivano le persone in
fila davanti a me
e vorrei finire qui ma purtroppo questi
comportamenti li riscontravo anche per
strada qui infatti ricevevo proposte
sessuali da uomini anziani e qui
partivano le solite domande sei libera
Quanto fai vieni
totalmente ignorando che avevo lo zaino
di scuola in spalla e totalmente
ignorando che ero alla fermata del
pullman come tutte le altre ragazze
e qui un'unica domanda mi sorgeva
spontanea Ma tutti bianchi tutti bianchi
Sono razzisti ce l'hanno tutti con me
Ed è proprio da questo rammarico ed in
questa circostanza che ho veramente
cominciato a pensare alle diversità e a
comprenderle profondamente ma non sono
qui per essere dipinta o vista come una
vittima sono qui per raccontarvi della
forza interna che mi si è creata grazie
a questi eventi
ho scoperto dei valori che ho fondato
che sono riuscita a proteggere e a
crescere li ho coltivati a 15 anni
Ed è proprio in quegli anni che ho
deciso di voler far parte di un
cambiamento del mio cambiamento E ora
che è una visione più matura e più
lucida Ho realizzato che voglio essere
la persona di cui avevo bisogno nella
mia gioventù con l'intento di sostenere
la solidarietà e diffonderla senza
barriere
Ed è proprio questo proposito che hai
deciso di candidarmi per essere
la giovane delegata d'Italia al
Consiglio d'Europa Il mio compito è
quello di creare progetti locali per
coinvolgere i giovani nella
partecipazione politica e questo si
collega molto bene con il lavoro svolto
dal Consiglio che è quello di tutelare e
promuovere i diritti umani e anche della
democrazia
e grazie a questo ruolo Finalmente sono
riuscita a esporre una visione della
società che volevo vedere senza filtri
ho finalmente potuto lottare per i
valori in cui tanto credevo aprendo un
dialogo sullo scarso coinvolgimento dei
giovani della diaspra nei processi di
cooperazione internazionale
e in quel momento ero salita da dubbi da
incertezze
dalla paura di non essere compresa
ancora una volta perché questa volta ero
in una classe più grande un aula magna
del parlamento E lì ho realizzato che
non tutti quelli come me non tutte le
donne non tutti i giovani hanno la
fortuna di essere qui
ho continuato a combattere per questi
valori in cui tanto credevo
intraprendendo un breve lavoro con l'ONU
un'esperienza concreta utile
e ho avuto il piacere di far parte di un
settore che mi stava tanto a cuore il
dipartimento dell'inclusione sociale e
della diversità
E qui ho osservato come i valori che
erano difesi e promossi venivano
veramente messi in pratica non soltanto
nel contesto lavorativo ma anche al di
fuori
Infatti ero circondata da colleghi
provenienti da tutte le parti del mondo
e pur essendo che eravamo così diversi
così distanti eravamo accomunati da un
solo scopo eliminare ogni forma di
discriminazione
questa esperienza hanno giovato ad una
trasformazione interna Infatti dopo
essere arrivata in Inghilterra
Ho notato come i giovani erano inclusi
nei processi direzionali di un'azienda
e io non ero abituata a vedere giovani
come leader
Infatti ero molto diffidente molto
dubbiosa
e
ero totalmente convinta che l'unico
contributo significativo in un'azienda
era esclusivamente dato da veterani da
saggi anziani e ritenevo che i giovani
non potessero permettersi il lusso di
essere supervisori senza dieci anni di
tirocinio minimo
E lì mi sono accorta che stavo creando
uno stereotipo
basato sulle mie esperienze
e mi sono accorta che stavo
discriminando allo stesso modo in cui io
ero a mia volta discriminata Ed è
proprio lì che ho cominciato a
riconoscere i miei preconcetti e a
seppellirli ho cominciato a essere più
aperta ad un dialogo onesto e
trasparente
ho smesso di essere influenzata da
opinioni esterne basate sull'assenza di
esempi concreti
ho veramente cominciato a creare un vero
e proprio libero pensiero
ed è grazie a questa questo processo di
riscoperta di trasformazione che ho
cominciato a implementare progetti per
coinvolgere i giovani
nell'amministrazione locale Ed è proprio
qui che sono ritornata dall'Inghilterra
alla mia cara città Brescia città in cui
sono nata e cresciuta che mi ha dato sia
lacrime che gioia gioia perché mi ha
donato una forza interna che mi sono
portata presto in questi anni e insieme
all'informagiovani e quel supporto del
comune ho deciso di creare un'assemblea
giovanile non una consulta giovanile che
è basata su una democrazia elettiva
ma un'assemblea basata sulla democrazia
partecipativa col fine di coinvolgere i
giovani
e di ogni percorsi di vita e di
organizzare eventi dove trattano di non
solo tematiche di inclusione ma senso
civico partecipazione politica
lavorando all'estero e essendo
circondata da persone provenienti da
ogni parte del mondo
ho aperto gli occhi su quanto la
differenza fosse un fattore non solo
importante ma efficace per il
raggiungimento di uno scopo comune
perché è proprio la diversità e
l'inclusione che aumentano le chance di
successo mi spiego tutti noi abbiamo un
bagaglio di conoscenze di tradizioni che
arricchiscono non soltanto i nostri i
nostri rapporti sociali ma anche i
nostri rapporti lavorativi per esempio
lavorando su un progetto finalizzato a
offrire strumenti e servizi di
integrazione e di accoglienza alle
vittime di tratta quattro aziende si
sono riunite dalla Spagna
dall'Inghilterra dalla Romania e
dall'Italia per migliorare le condizioni
economiche e sociali delle vittime
stesse
e qui per noi è stato importante prima
di cominciare il processo di
confrontarci di aprire un dialogo onesto
e sincero sulle nostre differenze
culturali abbiamo potuto osservare gli
stereotipi più comuni e più ottusi del
nostro tempo e dei nostri paesi e
abbiamo finalmente in quel momento
raggiunto una comprensione una chiarezza
abbiamo capito quanto quegli stereotipi
fossero infondati abbiamo capito
finalmente che potevamo imparare
qualcosa l'uno dall'altro
abbiamo Inoltre condiviso pratiche e
competenze esistenti Infatti insieme
abbiamo creato una piattaforma online
una piattaforma di supporto Non solo per
le vittime di tratta ma anche per i
volontari inclusi nel progetto
quindi qui si può notare che la
differenza costituisce un potenziale che
porta un vero e proprio Progresso
sociale
quindi la domanda non è come soffocare
le diversità Ma è Come lottare insieme
per una società più altruista Più
inclusiva e meno egoista che opera
veramente per il benessere pubblico
grazie a questa esperienza e queste
conversazioni ho finalmente capito una
cosa
ho capito che non tutti bianchi Sono
razzisti
i cambiamenti devono iniziare da noi
dai giovani attraverso il dialogo
attraverso la comunicazione
attraverso le azioni e soprattutto
sforzi concreti
perché non mi basta più lamentarmi a
casa
non mi basta più protestare per le
piazze Perché i grandi cambiamenti
quelli veri iniziano in ogni luogo in
cui ci troviamo iniziano nelle nostre
case
insegnando ai nostri figli quanto vari
il mondo iniziano nel nostro lavoro
creando un'atmosfera accogliente priva
di giudizio e iniziano nel nostro
vicinato
aprendoci a nuove conoscenze nuove
opportunità Nuovi Orizzonti Perché solo
così che potremo Creare una società
veramente in armonia che abbraccio la
varietà di ogni persona Grazie
[Musica]
Grazie Sharon
mi ha colpito moltissimo nel tuo Talk il
momento in cui hai parlato della persona
che avresti voluto incontrare cioè del
diventare la persona che avresti voluto
incontrare quando eri più piccola
dove e come Chi è Giorgio giovanissimo
adesso come succedeva a te In
quell'epoca dove come può cercare queste
persone sì Innanzitutto Secondo me è
importante cominciare a farsi delle
domande cominciare a usare i nostri
capacità critiche e non solo farsi
domande ma anche saper ascoltare perché
certe volte Questa è una cosa che ci
manca e veramente incuriosirci quindi
aprendoci a nuove conoscenze perché alla
fine secondo me
cambiare comunque portare un cambiamento
non inizia facendo grandi passi da
gigante ma iniziare il nostro piccolo
cioè
e quindi secondo perché è importante
cominciare dove siamo e utilizzare le
risorse che abbiamo per poi vedere
cambiamenti che noi vorremmo vedere
nella nostra comunità Certo ma hai
qualche ricordo nello specifico di
persone che quando tu cercavi questo
cambiamento ti hanno ispirato Sì
ovviamente ho fatto ricerca personale a
riguardo e ho cominciato a studiare
figure guida per me che mi hanno aiutato
in questo processo di riscoperta e
soprattutto è anche importante
circondarsi da persone a cui vorresti
aspirare a essere che è un penso che che
è un grande elemento di incoraggiamento
in questo senso quindi sì E adesso
abbiamo anche il tuo Talk che tra
qualche settimana sarà disponibile poi
in video sul portale naturalmente di Ted
Quindi sarà anche questo un
un'ispirazione Grazie mille per essere
stata con noi
[Applauso]
[Musica]